[Music]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday May 8th
10th 8th it's an even-numbered day in
May a commenter recently had an idea
that we should release a Brotherhood 2.0
calendar to increase the funds to
decrease worldsuck and I think that's a
great idea it would be exactly like a
regular calendar except without weekends
and also the date would always be wrong
Hank we're in the airport in New York
City on our way to go house-hunting in
Indianapolis this will be my first time
visiting Indianapolis as a you know
resident Hank there were several happy
birthday wishes that got lost in my
email that I'll have to show you on
Thursday but for now I don't have them
because we're in the airport and I don't
have my computer and I don't really know
what's going on and we got to go house
hunting we're very busy we got to meet
penny the realtor there's a lot going on
but I will show you those happy birthday
greetings on Thursday also during the
happy birthday top-secret project I
learned a lot of interesting things
about our nerdfighters for instance did
you know and this is entirely true one
of the nerdfighters is going to be
competing this year in the National
Spelling Bee in Washington DC Hank we
have a semi-professional speller Hank in
other news Maureen Johnson's book the
Bermudez triangle seems to have been
sort of halfway unbanned specifically
the school administration is now arguing
that they didn't ban the book at all in
the first place they just recommended
that it be banned and then removed it
from the shelf which somehow does not
constitute banning anyway it seems like
our letters have worked and now it's
just a matter of seeing if the school
superintendent agrees that the book
should stay on the shelves observation
people look at you funny when you scream
into a camera at the airport at 7:10 in
the morning hey Hank while we're here at
the airport I thought we might go to
Hudson News see what's going on in the
world
what's wrong with Brits baby is not a
sentence that ends in an exclamation
point I think most of that video was
filmed at like 7 o'clock this morning at
the airport and now we're in
Indianapolis and it's like 11 o'clock at
night and I only have about 30 minutes
to upload and edit and do everything
with my Brotherhood 2.0 video and I'm
extremely stressed out and plus we saw
like 12 houses today and they were all
nice but they also only work and it was
really really really really really
really really really stress on the last
thing I want to do is come home and have
to make a video
you know when I get stressed out you
know what I do I do this thing I do the
puffs I do the puffs up
I do the constant puffs up I've been
doing the puffs up all day you see Hank
in my life the puffs level has a direct
correlation to the stress level the
puffs level is high so the stress level
is high don't get me wrong
shopping for houses is really really
really fun it's exciting and it feels
good and the houses are interesting and
everything else but it's also scary
so the puffs level is high and the
stress level is high and Hank on
Thursday I'm going to need you to help
me pick a house I'll see you tomorrow
Brotherhood 2.0 would like to wish a
very belated but very happy 30th
birthday - Shannon James nerdfighters